spirit airlines battling some major
issues over the weekend and even into
today according to flightaware 89
flights have been canceled at harry reid
in the last 24 hours of course that made
a lot of travelers angry especially
because they weren't really sure the
exact reason why sally jeremiah at the
airport speaking to travelers fed up
with these massive cancellations from
various airlines over the past couple of
months
a lot of angry travelers finding out
last minute their flight is canceled not
knowing why when asked they are told due
to weather i think in the last couple of
weeks it's been
crazy busy because
you know well countries are lifting a
lot of their requirements and people are
just feeling more comfortable
in traveling which is showing a lot of
interest and bookings abby lagman is the
president of blissful travel company she
says just past weekend there were dozens
of delays and cancellations twitter was
going crazy about certain
airlines having flight cancellations and
and last minute notifications so
i think it's definitely something that
has been happening we lost over like a
couple thousand dollars on this cruise
and it's just
and like all i kept getting was you know
we understand we understand we're sorry
we were staying in line with like over
300 people in tears and crying and
everything like that and people who were
stuck who didn't have options to get
hotels or anything like that traveler
sarah jolie describes her experience as
a nightmare for others like jose
francisco alvarez he arrived saturday in
las vegas and now can't get out until
wednesday
[Music]
there's no information everyone is
desperate waiting for their flight i
would just wish that they could tell us
the truth
be like whether it was staffing shortage
or whatever sally haramiyo live local
now